We made a big effort this year to make Search more interactive...
...and you can see that with Google Instant.
And then more recently, we made those previews instant as well.
And earlier in the year, we launched new user interfaces for both web search and image search...
...to make it easier and to make it more intuitive,...
...to work with the results after you run a search.
And we're also making Search more intelligent.
We made several changes to results.
So now you can see things like a concert schedule or the answers to the questions...
...highlighted right in the snippet.
And we're also now starting to roll out Place Search...
...so when we know that you're looking for something that's in the neighborhood like an ice cream shop or something,...
...we'll pull reviews, web pages, the address, and a photo altogether for you.
We also doubled down on the ad side of the house.
In the past year, we've launched several new ad formats which we've told you about,...
...site links, seller rating ads.
Recently, we just added this product listing ads with photos and prices.
It makes sense that if I'm shopping for something like a coffee maker,...
...it's helpful to see more information in the ad.
But the biggest boost of all came from good old-fashioned ads quality improvements.
Q4 was our best quarter in years from a quality standpoint.
We launched over 20 updates which led to gains...
...that were nearly double those that we would normally see in a strong quarter.
So although we've been at this for years,...
...we're still finding lots and lots of ways to make ads better.